question est bien sûr tu répondras
thomas c'est tout sauf du libre tous
sortent du livre te dire que je me
souviens de toi après bien des cas on
magouille on magouille ira comme les
chiffres radio canada nico inquiète pas
c'est ici c'est la télé c'est magouille
et compagnie qu'est ce que la reine
d'egypte ça c'est sûr que tu t'en
souviens
ouais ouais ça y est c'est déjà ça bah
oui j'étais obligée d'y aller j'ai
démarré par sa pour les mettre bien sûr
en confiance qu'est ce que la reine
d'egypte cléopâtre a eu avant tout le
monde
une pince de scorpions qui lui servait
de bois ça dans une pâte de chacals qui
lui servait de peigne un papyrus qui lui
servait de sextoys une statue du nez de
gilles verdez qui lui servait de pioche
est placée en ma pire usa on servait de
sextoys elle mater des amateurs pour ça
vibre c'est une idée reçue
sauf que c'est une c'est une fausse idée
c'est là ça a été écrit par les
historiens après le règne de cléopâtre
qui était d'ailleurs le dernier pharaon
d'égypte oui c'est pas souvent pour la
dénigrer en fait parce que il ne
supportait pas que une femme de pouvoir
et pur régné sur l'egypte pendant aussi
longtemps donc on a inventé cette
histoire d'une reine infoman femmes
c'est une idée reçue ça bassères qui a
envie de ce enfin j'en sors nationaux en
tout cas sur michel maire rappelle à
l'époque on l'appelait néfertiti
jean-michel en tout cas à l'anecdote
c'est vrai qu'elle est frappante
et si ce n'est une légende tiffany
bonvoisin à lui libre parce que j'aimais
bien la curiosité est un vilain défaut
merci merci à wil émission sur rtl
temporaires tels étaient première radio
de france au xviiie siècle d'ajustement
est la première de france ou du succès
que voulait dire la phrase bonjour
comment allez vous
comment vont des affaires comment va la
famille comment va ton caca ou comment
vont les enfants capillaire de jean
michel mr été mis place et je penserai
lâcher car comment va-t-on cacahouète
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai ce que ça a
été à la selle est ce qu'il est ce que
ce que vous êtes bien d'aller à la selle
c'est effectivement ça il ya plein
d'autres expressions comme ça de la
langue française dont on soupçonne pas
le sens par exemple je sais pas si vous
êtes marié les uns et les autres mais
passer la bague au doigt
ouais ok ça veut dire quoi c'est très
c'est très visuel un patient voilà vous
a fallu est un acte sexuel tous en 1re
es tu le savais ça lui fait alors qu'une
chanson il ya beaucoup de comptines pour
enfants qui ont un double sens mais bon
comment le et marc fait-il pour séduire
sa femelle il lui serre la pince
il lui fait pipi dessus il lui casse une
patte du monstre sacré qu il lui casse
une pâte
non non non c'est quoi ma chérie ces
îles et ses pipelines s'il est exact
c'est vrai c'est un ca de nos chapitre
préféré avec avec sidonie on a appelé ça
la sexualité d'un plateau de fruits de
mer
ah oui donc j'ai effectivement
l'histoire duo marc ça commence comme ça
la danse de la séduction par les homards
c'est effectivement il a deux petits
trous en dessous des yeux et une urine
par là la balance des phéromones situé à
tyr la femelle sur l or c'est que le
début parce que you're in parler d'eux
comme castaldi div
lester b l'histoire elle retire sa
carapace la la femelle au mât pour
pouvoir aider souvent ils l'aident à la
retirer pour qu'ensuite ils réussissent
à et ils font l'amour l'un en face de
l'autre c'est très rare dans le règne
animal et au niveau de la moule on est
comme un plat de lamu le niveau de la
moule
elle a travaillé doivent selon ebs c'est
comme les huîtres en fait il ouvre non
ils balancent les gamètes mélange
ensuite j'ai dû ensuite y'a un p'tit
pour une 8 ya un embryon d'huîtres qui
va se poser quelque part sur un rocher
qui ensuite va grandir et je vois est le
plus haut mais c'est vrai il n'a pas
encore fait l'amour mais ça arrive à
l'origine que signifie l'expression
tirer son épingle du jeu à coït
interrompu interrompu interrompue juste
avant le moment crucial
une ancienne formule du jeu tirer à la
courte paille un tirage au sort qui
désignait la couturière que le roy
parlant arrêtera dans son lit lépingle
et le soir c'est là c'est un tirage au
sort pas du tout alors c'est le cas
c'est le coït interrompu exacte et ouais
bravo c'est à dire pas facile celle là
effectivement la cl est tentante céret
mari mais je comprends en fait que
c'était un jeu mettait des épingles sur
une sur une table et avec une ligne bâle
les femmes essayé de faire sortir les
pins de 2 de l'espace de jeux die
d'accord et ensuite c'est devenu
m'explique pas comment je te le dire le
symbole dav ça mais ça n'a rien à 9 ans
après je vous dis le dîner chez aulas on
a choisi la tâche choisi oui c'est sûr
qu'à la plage en a plein d'autres mais
ils sont tellement mal
toi avant le président qui logeaient
dans le palais de l'elysée les
supporters du psg les orphelins de
guerre des sapeurs pompiers ou des post
rage c'est sa mère avait la bonne
réponse
évidemment c'était quasiment un hôtel de
passe
à sa construction le palais de l'elysée
c'est une histoire géniale parce que le
celui qui fait construire le palais de
l'elysée c'est le comte d'evreux
on est au début du xviiie 1720 et il le
fait construire écoutez bien il le fait
construire avec l'argent de sa femme
d'accord et qu'est-ce qui fait le soir
de la mégateuf qu'il organise dans le
futur palais de l'élysée ramène des
filles est ce qui fait il répudie sa
femme et il installe sa maîtresse à la
place donc ça c'est le point de départ
du palais dali c'était vous si ensuite
je vais pas jouer pas que vous faire un
pc il ya le week-end sera installée la
pompadour sa maîtresse et c'est sous la
révolution qu'effectivement c'est devenu
quasiment un hôtel de passe et qu'on
organisait des fêtes au rez-de-chaussée
et à l'étagé les chambres a fait rêver
quels mots a donné son nom au tennis le
nom pénis le verbe tenir l'adjectif
tendu où le mot tatane opus c'est un
grand joueur de tennis thomas ab à 91 au
dessus de moi qu'il m'a battu à rennes
et pas de bêtises dirait le lever tenir
tenez devenir très bonne réponse est oui
ça vient de tenir ses serveurs de jeu de
paume à l'italien du jeu de paume oui le
jeu de paume c'est un lancer du tennis
en mai et même les comment compter les
points 15 30 40 en fait c'est au jeu de
paume on avance et 15 c'est ça qu'il
fait les règles sont ultra compliqué
j'ai joué une fois où je passais le le
terrain ça ressemble un peu à un terrain
de pelote basque et d'ailleurs il ya une
expression de langue française qui vient
de là l'expression épater la galerie
ça vient de là ça vient de là parce que
sur le côté gauche du terrain
il ya une galerie dans laquelle le
public ouvert qu'à s'installer et quand
il y avait un coût qui était magnifique
on l'a le public sert à eau etc et on
n'est pas tes la galerie jeux de mains
jeux de vilains aussi ça c'est de là je
mange de vilains benjamin jeu de vilain
c'est au départ ont joué à la main au
jeu de paume bangor et puis il ya des
raquettes qui ont commencé à apparaître
et qui pouvait se payer des raquettes
évidemment les plus riches
bien sûr donc les plus riches jouer au
jeu de paume avec des raquettes et plus
pauvres continuent à jouer à la main
donc c'est donc jeux de mains jeux de
vilains ce qu'un vilain cet impôt c'est
une bonne élection
lui toute la nuit les chouettes c'est
une très bonne émission ce soir est vrai
un soixante et un tel truc incroyable a
décidé de vendre l'article
l'artiste piero manzoni cje et rolland
conserve une photo classe d'isabelle
morini-bosc avec le cap et gauche ou à
portrait réalisé avec ses crottes de nez
dégueulasse là la caf animons gauche
beaucoup voulaient les troncs c'est
tentant quand même là sur gilles verdez
encore une bonne réponse à vos bonnes
idées mais s'est mêlée à lever la main
avec cheryl a levé le nez aussi donc
c'est ça après tout âge il commence
après l'oeuvre
non ça je sais pas ben ça s'appelait
merde d'artistes ouais c'est pas il
s'est pas pris la tête le mec ça a été
vendu en 2015 le nom enfin chez pas
c'est tellement débile
ouais plus de 200000 euros la conserve
la tête 61 merde d'artistes dessus et ça
a été vendu aux enchères en voit les
gens se régale dans votre livre s'il ya
énormément d'anecdotes d'information
d'histoire on voudrait des explications
sur onze m'en faire grève savez c'est à
signifier qu à l'époque la wii alors
faire grève c'est assez 1 c'est drôle
parce que c'est un contresens historique
aujourd'hui les grévistes et ceux qui
s'arrêtent de travailler
sauf que il faut imaginer paris avant la
construction de l'hôtel de ville
donc la place devant ce qu'est l'hôtel
de ville aujourd'hui c'était une longue
plage d'accord de sable qui descendait
jusqu'à la scène et on appelle ça une
grève là ce qui laisse en douceur
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'os à peine une grève
donc c'était la place de grève et paris
était un port il y avait évidemment
beaucoup de bateaux qui venait livrer
leur cargaison
il fallait de la main d'oeuvre pour
décharger la cargaison est donc on
venait sur la place de grève pour
travailler j'adore donc les grévistes
étaient ceux qui venaient bosser la
place de brest et le pôle emploi de
l'époque en quelque sorte à à paris et
et par translation quand il ya eu au
début du 19ème
les premiers mouvements sociaux les
premiers arrêts de travail les gens qui
ne voulaient plus travailler se
réunissaient ou sur la place de grève
les grévistes sont devenus ce qu'ils ne
voulaient plus tard c'est magnifique
mais aussi du people people et je me
suis régalé avec le people on apprend on
l'est on a vu les photos partout on
apprend la fosse syncope de claude
françois
le 16 mars 1970 en plein concert et
c'est vrai qu'on en a beaucoup parlé ça
il est victime d'un malaise à marseille
c'était un faux baissent pour relancer
sa carrière exactement il y avait une
petite hattie coup de mou dans sa
carrière mais effectivement il simule
une une syncope mais vraiment c'est à
dire qu'il est évacué
il évacue et de l'ancienne et son
manager dramatise un peu l'événement
d'hier il va vraiment mal et c'est pour
que ses fans se remobiliser alors il ya
un autre truc que j'ai aimé aussi on le
sait peu mais à la base daniel balavoine
vous connaissez la chanson je ne suis
pas un héros
à la base cette chanson daniel balavoine
l'écrit pour johnny hallyday
voilà effectivement c'est ça il
enregistre johnny et qu'est ce qui se
passe après alors john il enregistre
demeure ne sait plus sur quel album et
c'est une période où johnny lui aussi la
une période de creux on est au début des
années 80 il a toute sa carrière il eu
l'intelligence johnny hallyday d'aller
chercher les jeunes talents et celui qui
vient de cartonner c'est balavoine
l'année précédente dont qui demande à
balavoine de lui écrire c'est cette
chanson elle est dans son album est en
fait la chanson elle passe totalement
inaperçu c'est d'ailleurs qu'on en fait
les tice dans l'album de thé au départ
et personne n'en voit pas s'il n'en fait
pas un single fin veille toujours sur un
album il ya deux trois singles sorte
rien donc le flop absolu et c'est johnny
qui va dire à balavoine et ben écoute tu
devrais l'enregistrer toi aussi et c'est
avec avec byron que c'est devenu un tube
et là où l'histoire est belle c'est que
enfin belle après la mort de daniel
balavoine johnny la réenregistrer et la
joue en concert
écoutez regardez la la la la la version
de johnny que je ne suis pas un héros
[Musique]
je suis fatigué secours c'est tant mieux
je ne suis pas
[Musique]
d'accord
c'est pas
à
[Musique]
alors il ya d'autres aussi ont parlé de
johnny aussi en parlant de catherine
deneuve
catherine deneuve et johnny e sortie a
pas très long et exactement passé sortie
d'un amant leur liaison secrète mais la
prime de 9 cm à une amitié une amie de
toutes les revues comme l'indiqué
amoureuse secondaire isabelle morini
bosc
maintenant il ya une maison était mignon
le savait déjà que johnny et moi je ne
savais pas en parlant de se faire un peu
ensemble
j'ai un gros gros scoop sur françois
hollande là qui va sortir demain dont je
vous parlerai tout alors ouais françois
hollande apparemment je peux vous dire
il est chaud cacao il échoue apparemment
ah ouais il fait pas que des cérémonies
je vous le dis mais aussi à d'autres
alors en santé j'aimerais qu'on vienne
sur un truc c'est le sommeil les secrets
du sommeil vous dites à l'antiquité au
moyen âge on se levait après trois ou
quatre heures de sommeil pour discuter
ou même marcher pendant une heure et
après on se recoucher cissé moussa ben
génial c'est que j'ai repensé ce matin
parce que j'ai une nuit pourri je me
suis réveillé trop quatre fois et je
peux dire que j'étais chiffon comme
c'est pas permis
donc ça va pas marcher mais je pense que
c'est lié au cycle de sommeil c'est à
dire que si tu réussis à faire un ou
deux cycles complets effectivement tu
peux avoir dormi trois heures tu es en
forme et si tu refais un cycle complet
ça ça peut fonctionner quand on ne sait
pas si alain certains d'entre vous
isabelle beaucoup mais adore le plus
long mais qu'ont fait les matinales en
radiant elle a fait durant deux fois
bien sûr ah oui
m or quand tu l as trouvé une technique
à bord pendant l'émission c'est vraiment
ces trois heures d'antenne tranquille tu
dors dans le temps sur le fait souvent
la nuit aussi pour rallumer le feu pour
mettre du feu dans la nuit de la
chouette feu merci à les bains et thomas
hugues thomas vraiment rester est ce que
maintenant alors allé jusqu'à se poser
une question est ce que tu essaies de te
coller tu peux y aller mais n'a pas
d'oreilles 140 149 d'accord quel nom
parce que il paraît que tu as une
mémoire était hypermnésique noël quelle
personnalité à la fin du 19e siècle et
bars qui a créé le kinétoscope d'accord
écoutez bien à tenter de créer un écrou
scop la microfinance renée professeur
accroc fait des gros films uniques et
avec les morts c'est une époque le la
fin du 19e où c'est vraiment la grande
mode de faire tourner les tables comme
une quête voltaire non c'est une bonne
question ça j'ai besoin de vous c'est
votre action je voudrais me déplacer
qu'est ce que vous faites monsieur oui
ce que vous faites
bonjour qu'est ce qu'il a cette
politique fait que vous faites là où
déménager là bas ça pulse comme elle
s'appelle comment votre collègue edison
d'accord alors excusez-moi ya un petit
souci c'est vrai que ça ne peut pas
encore au point
c'est mieux en mieux et je pense que ce
serait pas thomas edison
[Applaudissements]